To showcase the importance of both the field of view and its relationship to
the focal length lens I'm going to show you a series of pictures a friend of
mine, a colleague of mine at Georgia Tech, Henry Christenson.
Professor Christensen took from his apartment and
this would be actually interesting for all of you to see
interesting perspective of the Georgia Tech campus from the city of Atlanta.
Here is basically the focal of the camera we're using or
the lens we're using is 12 millimeter.
This is the view, 24 millimeter, 50 millimeter,
85 millimeter lens, moving to a 116.
220 millimeter, all the way to 300 millimeters.
So we've gone from 12 millimeter to 300 millimeter, and now, of course,
you're seeing the iconic Georgia Tech tower in front of our football stadium.
Right behind was the Coca-Cola campus.
So this is an interesting way of kind of now showing you the values,
to field of views really kind of getting focused in.
Let's look at it a little bit in backward direction.
And forward again.
Let's look at the same images in a different form next.